war
war never changes over the course of 16
games call of duty has become one of the
world's biggest gaming franchises
although many players may have their own
personal favorites in the series none is
as vastly popular as the modern warfare
sub-series with the modern warfare 2
reboot just around the corner these are
10 things you didn't know about modern
warfare 2019
number 10 teddy bears of war when
playing on the gunfight map trench
random numbers can be found scratched
onto various surfaces around the map and
switch every time the map is reloaded go
to the bunker and shoot the numbers into
the keypad and the door will open
to reveal the most nefarious teddy bears
and other stuffed toys situated around
the war table making plans
exploring the bunker further leads to a
locked door with a code right next to a
telephone in the room input the code
into the keypad and voila the phone next
to the door will ring if you answer the
caller on the other end will immediately
hang up and the secret door will unlock
revealing a giant teddy bear the stuffed
foe is not happy to be disturbed however
firing two miniguns that deal real
damage
and then explodes
number nine pied piper on the cheshire
park map five mouse traps appear
randomly throughout the level after
shooting the last trap it will turn into
a piece of cheese look for the grocer
and find the wheel of cheese with the
chunk missing
okay so i made this sound way too easy
when i was writing this out first of all
each mouse trap spawns individually so
you have to do the first to get the
second they're not all on the same map
at the same time second the wheel of
cheese is in the grocer yes but it might
also be in seven different places around
the map depending on where it spawns
like the fish and chips restaurant which
is where i found it so if you're trying
to do this easter egg all i can say
is good luck
next go to the fountain in the middle of
garden square and press the button to
place offering candles should appear
around the statue and rats should start
pouring out from the left bench all you
have to do now is sit back and enjoy the
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number eight call of duty kaiju if you
thought that godzilla and king kong were
the first massive monsters to show up in
a call of duty game
guess again if you load up the station
map with the overkill perk and lmgs in
both weapon slots head to the concrete
walls on the side of the train station
shoot the six walls until they crumble
each revealing a number and the final a
keypad from left to right shoot the
numbers into the keypad and then turn
around and hop on top of the train to
see what happens
[Music]
[Music]
number seven catch phrases throughout
the course of modern warfare there are
auditory references to the previous
modern warfare titles when practicing
alex's sniping skills during the mission
highway of death after hitting the
watermelon target hadir states that
that's
that
this is a word for word reference to
gaz's line during the tutorial of call
of duty 4 modern warfare your fruit
killing skills are remarkable another
line for line delivery is during the
mission going dark in the game a
disoriented player gets pulled to their
feet by captain price he shouts
we are leaving this quote is only one
word off from his iconic on your feet
soldier we are leaving during the crew
expendable mission in the original
modern warfare he also hearkens back to
another crew expendable line when
entering the electronics store during
the piccadilly circus mission price
relays the order check those corners the
same order he gives during the beginning
of crew expendable check close corners
in a cut scene for going dark when
approaching a police roadblock captain
price describes his plan
this refers to a famous mission in the
original modern warfare in which a nuke
takes out a marine squadron in real life
shock in awe was also the name for the
type of military operation that the
united states used during the iraq war
number six
proto-verdansk before the official
release of warzone you could get a sneak
peek at the entire verdansk map
gamespot's call of duty commissioner
aaron sampson was able to fly out of the
constraints of the multiplayer map
superstore to find a prototype map of
verdansk for call of duty warzone
assuming that this boundary break was
available at launch in october of 2019
fans could get a sneak peek into what
was to come five months before war zone
dropped in march of 2020
number five lawyer up introduced in 2019
during the first season of modern
warfare's multiplayer the introduction
of operator mara caused writer and
photographer clayton hagan to sue
infinity ward according to polygon hagen
filed a copyright infringement lawsuit
in the texas court claiming that mara
was based on a character in one of his
short stories hagen's lawyers stated in
addition to hiring the same talent they
also hired the same makeup professional
who had prepared the talent for hagen's
kade janus photographs they instructed
the makeup professional to prepare the
talent exactly as she had done for
hagin's kate janna's photographs they
instructed her to style the talent's
hair exactly as she had done for hegen's
kate janus photographs even using the
same hairpiece extension initially
published in february of 2021 the
polygon article didn't note any
resolution to the case
i couldn't find any additional
information on how the case was settled
either
number four mini-map attack during the
playstation exclusive beta for modern
warfare infinity ward eradicated the
mini-map from the hud unless a uiview
was deployed in competitive play instead
of the classic mini-map they relied on
sound design and an in-game compass to
let players find each other however the
player response was so strong that
infinity ward quickly re-implemented the
mini-map within a few days although a
controversy at the time of its
implementation most pro players praised
infinity ward for their communication
and quick compromises concerning player
feedback what was left over though in
the final game was a confusing hybrid
system where players could appear on
either the original compass or mini-map
or both depending on a large number of
factors
number three so here i am during the
piccadilly circus mission one of the
dead bodies has a very familiar looking
tattoo the iconic logo belongs to
neversoft the now disbanded development
team behind the tony hawk series of
games
number two honing your skills during the
sequences where you play as the younger
version of pharah she is not as
tactically aware and refined in her
skills as a soldier higher recoil slower
reloads and an inability to reload while
aiming down sights all add to the
immersion of her inexperience another
layer of detail comes during the
flashbacks when she is held as a
prisoner of war her exhaustion
malnourishment and torture add to her
lack of mobility
number one
back to the north pole captain price on
the winter docks multiplayer map if you
shoot the weather vane on top of the
clock tower right at midnight a
lightning bolt will strike the vein this
will cause a surge of electricity to
ripple over the power lines and spawn
santa into the map santa will fly by for
a second and then disappear with two
lines of flames burning behind him just
like in the movie back to the future
that's not the end of the secret though
because something isn't quite right
about jolly old saint nick and his
trusted reindeer rudolph the closer look
at the sleigh unveils that santa is
captain price and rudolph is riley from
call of duty ghosts
although call of duty games get a
reputation for being thrown together
because of their yearly release schedule
the 2019 reboot of modern warfare proves
that infinity ward could put together a
new style of call of duty game with a
well-planned year full of maps modes and
weapon releases the level of detail fun
and goofy secrets throughout the game
elevate the entire experience to
something more than just another call of
duty game in fact the animations and
attention to detail were so well done
that both call of duty cold war and call
of duty vancard kept the same animations
from modern warfare 2019. it's been a
blast uncovering the intricacies and
secrets of development and the
controversies and hidden treasures
surrounding the game itself check out
our everything to know guide if you're
hyped for call of duty modern warfare 2.
catch me on twitter at stewie review and
for all things video games keep it here
at gamespot